corfu is one of greece's most
popular islands for holiday makers with
two and a half
million visitors here in 2019 the talk
was about
over tourism no longer last year's
tourism revenue fell by three quarters
because of covet 19.
and because tourism is the main industry
eight in ten people were left unemployed
and dependent on state aid
many businesses have gone bankrupt eleni
ricikopoulou
she feels lucky to be able to reopen
i worry about going out of business i'm
not optimistic this year
i can't support the shop the expenses
are really high
i'm holding on by my fingernails now
that we've lost a whole season
industry leaders here say they'll be
lucky to reach just 45 percent
of their 2019 income this year
it's a different story on baksi just
south of corfu
the islanders managed to hold on to half
their business during the worst of the
pandemic last year
and believe they'll do even better now
that's because baksi
was developed as a luxury destination in
the 1970s
when europeans started to build fillers
here and then rented them out
to other europeans to offset the cost
pak is a small island without hotels
there are villas and rented apartments
tourists trust because they don't come
into contact with broadly used spaces
the villas are clean and owners try to
keep them disinfected
stefanos fujaros who rents apartments
says half his business is repeat tourism
a level of loyalty hard to find on corfu
there are two and a half thousand
residents on baxi and authorities here
say they have so far vaccinated about
two-thirds of the population
compared to the national average of
under 30 percent
so this island is selling itself as a
covered safe destination
something larger tourism hotspots cannot
do
back sea is certainly doing well as a
luxury destination
the four-month season keeps people in
money the rest of the year
such profits haven't gone unnoticed on
corfu
where a dozen five-star hotels have gone
up in the last fifteen years
coffeats are now seeking to cash in on
those more expensive markets
we're at a turning point we depend on
the british market for 40 percent of our
tourism
we're trying to attract new markets like
china the united arab emirates
kazakhstan and azerbaijan we believe
this is the future
the trend towards luxury locals hope
will ensure the sun never sets
on greek tourism john cerropolos al
jazeera on kofu
and baksi